es ist mittwoch es ist 10.30 wie
versprochen die nici gary und ich wir
sind da wir freuen uns dass ihr alle
wieder dabei sein
zum dritten teil unseres online
trainings der inhalt von heute wird ein
sensomotorik training sein was bedeutet
das was trainieren wir damit wofür
braucht man das da geht es einerseits
darum die tiefliegende muskulatur zu
trainieren und andererseits haben auch
das gleichgewicht und die koordination
mit ins boot holen um entsprechend gut
trainiert aus dem vormittag zu kommen
wir brauchen das ganze gerade jetzt in
der kalten jahreszeit um beispielsweise
die sturzprophylaxe zu verbessern zu
trainieren damit man wenn man
beispielsweise auf eine eisplatte steigt
nicht umfeld nicht auf der nase landet
sondern entsprechend den sturz abfangen
kann
das geht dann wenn ich eine gut
trainierte sensomotorik habt und ganz
spezifisch für den einsatz soldaten man
stelle sich vor es ist finster es ist in
der nacht das ist im wald und es ist
irgendwo eine annäherung
die gemacht werden muss und der soldat
steigt das eine rutschige wurzel fällt
hin stürzt verletzt sich das passiert
alles nicht wenn die sensomotorik gut
drin jedes und gut passt ja für die
körperliche belastung gestern und
vorgestern ist vielleicht ein kleiner
muskelkater das ist in ordnung heute
versprochen wird körperlich weniger
belastend und morgen dafür doppelt
intensiv auf ein schönes training nicht
jährige salz bereit
jawohl dann ein kurzes aufwärmen wir
beginnen mit lockerem laufen am stand
wir werden heute so ganz grob immer
wieder einen rhythmus einbauen 30
sekunden ungefähr im einband stand
beispielsweise stehen 30 sekunden die
zweite seite ist ungefähr einrichten
können sie es ist nicht ganz so genau
aber so grob 30 sekunden wird unser
zeitablauf immer seien genau die
varianten auch hier wiederum mit hand
beim anspringen boxen auf schattenboxen
alles möglich auch im bereich der
wirbelsäule wir haben uns ganz kurz auf
das heißt wir haben wieder das rumpf
drehen in der vorbeuge mit drinnen das
machen wir gerne bitte gerne schöne
position langsam vom linken auf das
rechte bein wechseln
kerner und dann lassen wir wieder in
unterschiedlichsten varianten die
bewegung am stand das ist dasselbe wie
die letzten zwei tage
und so wie die letzten tage immer wieder
ähnliche übungen in anderen varianten
gefragter machen wir das heute auch das
einzige was gleich bleibt wir sind auch
heute wieder getestet worden wir haben
das ergebnis bereits bekommen wir sind
alle wieder negativ getestet das heißt
unser abstand ist kein problem genau
einmal auf den rumpf trennen der
vorbeugend diesmal etwas dynamischer ihr
seht wir haben wieder unsere trainings
sieg für unser trainings equipment wir
haben wieder eine trainingsmatte dort
diesmal haben sie zusammengerollt um
eine mobile unterlage zu haben als
ausweich mittel haben wir auch noch ein
zusammengerollt des hand durch darauf
als einer keine mathe hat alles kein
problem
die nici macht das ganze ohne schuhe des
barfuß der guerillas die schuhe an
das ist einfach unterschiedliche
varianten wieder ohne schuhe ist das
genauso gut dass das zu spüren dass
entsprechend das gefühl zu bekommen also
wie ihr wollt so richtet ihr jetzt ein
die 30 sekunden für die vorstadt
makellos mit der ersten übung ein
weinstand rechte seite das heißt linkes
bein anheben und dann hinein spüren in
die fußsohle was passiert der druck geht
von der linken auf die rechte von vorne
nach hinten mal variierte bisserl die
die bomben sicher stehen im einbein
stand ja die können gerne die hände
einmal verschränken und nicht zum
gleichgewicht halten verwenden
und wenn das super funktioniert man kann
ja beispielsweise auch meine augen
klemme schließen
okay wir wechseln die seite dass man
nicht eine seite zu viel belasten
was ist wichtig meint ein standard fonds
muss man schauen was ich die grundbasis
denn genau hier aber besser hätte es
nicht formulieren können
wir wechseln wieder in den bei einigen
stand locker aus auch wenn das
körperliche jetzt nicht ganz so
anstrengend intensiv ist die
tiefliegende muskulatur braucht genauso
ihre regeneration abermals netz und
intensiv spürt wie eine große muskulatur
die außen drauf liegt jeweils wie kann
man diese übung noch ein bisserl
intensivieren niki den einband stand
wir können beispielsweise den kopf
bewegen was gibt es noch genau so macht
man das so machen wir das jetzt
eigentlich nicht gemacht sondern mit der
kopfbewegung garrett bitte einmal auf
die matte oder auf das handtuch aus der
liebe ist
30 sekunden lassen wir wieder laufen und
versucht ein gleichgewicht zu finden und
entsprechend das auszugleichen
ja und vom ausgleichen lebt das training
je sicherer ich stehe desto weniger
trainingseffekt auf der tiefliegenden
muskulatur
je unsicherer dass sie stehe und je mehr
das sie ausgleichen muss ja da kann man
zum beispiel einen schub gegeben dass
man da was ausgleichen muss ja desto
besser desto mehr wird die art von
training seite wechseln und musiker
gerne glaubt sie immer wieder am bauch
ja das heißt nicht vergessen
rumpfmuskulatur anspannen hintern
anspannen die grundspannung die
körperliche grundspannung wie man die
letzten zwei tagen schon immer wieder
mit hatten die trainieren mit ok ja wir
machen wieder kurz den beinen stand
herunter von der matte wir haben jetzt
einmal einen gleichgewichtspreis
eingesetzt da kommt war sein okay es
passiert aber er muss arbeiten und
ausgleichen auch mitarbeiten
und jetzt da machen wir eine
koordinative übungen mal ganz kurz zu
erklären
ich sage jetzt da 1 2 3 und 4 die nici
verkehre und ihr hier läuft einmal ganz
locker an stand wenn ihr von mir hört 1
geht die linke hand nach oben
rund 3 wieder runter und das möglichst
rasch bei 2 die rechte hand gerade bei 3
hebt sie das linke knie hoch und bei 4
das rechte ok bereit am stand laufen
jeder sein tempo ein bisschen locker
rates schneller so genau
der kopf muss arbeiten da ist mit dabei
ja es kombiniert man mal zwei zahlen so
möglichst schnell hintereinander also
nicht gleichzeitig sondern
hintereinander 34 14 männer und hier
korrigiert sich selber geschaut dass das
dicke davon geräte sind auch nicht
fehlerfrei sondern schaue nur auf mich
selber versucht sich zu konzentrieren
weil sie das gut hingekriegt
34 ja genau und wieder auslaufen hatten
ein bisschen bewegung zwischen drinnen
es ist ein bisschen das herz kreislauf
system wieder aktiviert wir gehen noch
einmal in den händen stand bitte wieder
auf die matte beziehungsweise am boden
und jetzt versucht man einerseits einmal
die augen zu schließen weil man sicher
am boden stehen und andererseits über
die eine zusätzliche bewegungen über das
bein vielleicht durchleben knie heben
arme bewegen diesen ausgleichenden reiz
dieses wackeln ja zu trainieren das zu
erreichen braucht uns gespannt internets
gespannt bei der nici sieht man das ganz
gut wie gesagt ich gebe gern einmal
wieder ein super dass sie mehr
ausgleichen muss dass sie für sie jahren
trainingsreiz hat wir wechseln gleich
wieder die seite gerne schön ausgleichen
ihr sicherer wie gesagt dass man steht
desto weniger trainingsreiz auf der
tiefliegenden muskulatur hatte die
unsicherheit steht desto mehr trainiert
man dieses ausgleichen das wo man hin
wollen und wieder ausrasten aus lockern
herunter genau hier können sie sich noch
erinnern gestern haben wir die übung im
kap-staat sich gehabt den ausfallschritt
dann haben wir gestern ohne mobile
unterlage gemacht heute macht man einen
mit einer mobilen unterlage das heißt es
jetzt nicht im fokus 45 sekunden so
viele ausfallschritte wie möglich zu
machen um meine kraft zu steigern
sondern wir machen 30 sekunden in der
position des ausbauschritt und versuchen
unsere beinachse so stabil wie möglich
zu haben und das entsprechend
auszugleichen dass man sicher stehen
nicht gut auf die bitten dass du den
atem an
90 grad dreht das manchmal der
längsrichtung noch kann eine
ausfallschritt position einnehmen
genau und wenn er jetzt oder her gehe
und mir das anschauen die nici geht in
den ausfallschritt hinunter dann muss
die beinachse stimmen das knie darf
nicht mehr gewinnen gehen das darf nicht
noch außen gehen und es wird doppelt
schwierig man das ganze auf einer
mobilen unterlage passiert wie dem
handtuch oder mathe okay das heißt jeder
von euch geht einmal in die position
ausfallschritt und versucht einen
ausfallschritt langsam zu machen und
sich auf das auszugleichen das
ausgleichen zu konzentrieren
das dass der fuss entsprechend arbeitet
und das ausgleichen muss ja war zwar
drei mal zwei drei wiederholungen dann
wechselt die nici bitte mal die seite
wer beim gerry schmit schaut hat ja da
gary ist dabei und macht das ganze so
dynamisch additiv bei euch die das schon
wirklich gut können diese schob armee
trainiert haben die können natürlich
auch dynamisch auf die mobile unterlage
hineingehen
das ist aber schon eine fortgeschrittene
variante das ist nicht die standard
einsteiger variante sondern da muss ich
schon ein wirklich gutes gefühl für mein
körper entwickelt haben ok kurze pause
kurz aus lockern
gerne auch ein schluck trinken genau
kennt sich vorbereiten wir will ich
wiederhole noch einmal eins ist die
linke hand 2 ist die rechte hand 3 ist
das linke knie
wie ist das rechte knie wir kombinieren
gleich wieder zwei vielleicht auch drei
zahlen so schnell wie möglich das ganze
versuchung nachzumachen laufen am stand
geht schon los
314 ja nicht gerne wenn er beobachten
können wir immer noch 142 ja geht ja
super konzentriert sich tatsächlich so
ein so
dh es muss schneller gehen
und drinnen gehabt dass bayernweit dabei
zwar drei mal die hände genau 34 12
gesenkt da muss man schon relativ lange
darüber nachdenken dass man es richtig
macht genau wie gesagt nicht zu
kompliziert nicht überfordernd aber
nicht unterfordert es muss immer sein
ausgleich da sein passt kurz auslagern
wir gehen von den ausfall schritten in
den vierfüßlerstand okay wie schaut das
gerät sagt uns das einmal vor genau der
klassische vier füße weil man nur zwei
füße haben ist die arme sind am boden
und die knie sind am boden ich habe
einen neutralen rücken
das heißt in der natürlichen schwung der
wirbelsäule sollte da rücken bleiben und
dass der position her mal die rechte
hand hoch genau wichtig ist dass die
spannung im becken und im rumpfbereich
bleibt okay
und um das ganze ein bisserl in einem
sensomotorik touch kannst wieder
runtergehen danke zu geben nimmst du die
matte auf die knie
also die knie auf die matte soll ist
richtig und machen wir das ja wohl
einfach die hand ausstrecken und
versuchen das ganze auszugleichen du
kannst du egal die hand wieder dazu
nehmen alle linke hand an der rechten
hand das wie gesagt einmal die
standard-variante einmal die etwas
intensivere über die mccanns auch das
beine ausstrecken immer wieder die
spannung die grundspannung ist gegeben
seit jahren gibt das handtuch du kannst
eine hand auf hand aufgeben und die
andere hand dann in die luft geben so
musste wieder mehr greifen und mehr
ausgleichen gerne selbständig das
beiname wechseln und die hand einmal
wechseln und ihr gleich aus und ganz
kompliziert und schwierig und feature
ausgleichen ist dann wenn ich meine knie
und zb die hand auf einer mobilen
unterlage hätte wie einer matte und
anhand durch jetzt mal kurze pause und
schauen uns das ok kurz aus lockern
nicht gefühlte bereit bereits super g
wieder die matte dazu für euch zu hause
hinten ein handtuch voran die matte oder
umgekehrt der zweimal hat kann das
natürlich auch nehmen und erst dann
versuchen wir mal die linke hand und das
rechte bein auszustrecken und da sieht
man schon deutsche wieder was zum
ausgleichen da ja ein paar sekunden
halten und seite wechseln
genau und dieses wie gesagt ich
wiederhole mich da dieses ausgleichend
dieses zittern dieses versuchen die
position zu halten
das ist das wichtige worum es geht bei
dem training einmal auf die seite
wechseln
bei carry markt ist in der hardcore
variante im liegestütz das ist natürlich
doppelt schwierig da braucht man schon
gewisse grundkraft auch seite wechselt
noch einmal
wer die kraft hat kann es natürlich in
der position einmal probieren
wichtig dabei ist aber dass sie dort
versucht auszugleichen dass mein becken
wieder gerade ist dass sie dort nicht
mitgehen
ok aus la paz kämen gerne seine matte
zurück
wir haben jetzt da im einbein stand der
arbeit wir haben ausfallschritte und den
vierfüßlerstand wir haben drei übungen
gemacht ganz wichtig für euch ist das
jetzt diese bewegungen dieses
ausgleichen versucht sie in euren alltag
zu integrieren ja wie kann das
ausschauen wird jetzt vermutlich nicht
im vierfüßlerstand in der u-bahn fahren
das wird vermutlich den einen oder
anderen ungläubigen blick auf sich
ziehen
aber ihr kennt zum beispiel hergehen und
den ein weinstand zu hause beim
zähneputzen trainieren ja also zum
beispiel zehn minuten also zehn minuten
30 sekunden längs 30 sekunden rechts
zweimal wechseln dabei zähne putzen und
wie es dort so meine kinder immer wieder
solange die qualität des zähneputzens
nicht darunter leidet machen wir das
wenn irgendwann die zimmer seien dafür
keine bomben sich einmal stand stehen
dann haben wir forschen schwergewicht
gewinnt ja ok nächste übung der sieht ab
den kann man genauso nicht als kraft
übung als bauchmuskelübungen gestalten
sondern eben zum ausgleichen verwenden
garridos setzt die bitte auf santos traf
genau in dem thema
und jetzt das auf sie aufpassen müsse
dass wir nicht nach hinten um falls das
heißt ihr kennt das einmal staaten mit
dem
einen am boden das ist einmal die etwas
lockerere variante die beine am boden
dann geht es mit den oberkörper ein
stück zurück und schaut einmal ob ihr
deutscher ausgleichen müsst wenn ihr
noch nicht ausgleichen müsste einmal ein
bein hoch ja wenn das immer noch zu
wenig ist hebt das zweite bein hoch
kommt mit den oberkörper wieder raus und
wir setzen auf eine beginnt es fertig
zum zittern auf andere ist die ganze
energie in bewegung und das ist genau
der punkt was man schon gesagt haben das
ist es was man brauchen kurze pause
beine wieder runter geht das anhand
durch genauso wie heißt mit einem bein
probieren das zweite dazu und ich musste
wieder ausgleichen und wenn es jetzt
kann er bei der übung sowie so unter
spannung seien ja dann gehe er stickel
nach hinten mit den oberkörper streckt
die beine vielleicht dazu aus ja und
dann kommen wir wieder vor aber es muss
man dinge die muss man einfach viel
machen
und wie gesagt in dem fall bewegen wir
uns in dem bereich was struck geht oder
nicht geht ja und dann haben wir die
richtige intensität für die tiefliegende
muskulatur nicht gesagt du vielleicht
auch noch einmal die variante ein bein
ist hoch 1 ist nieder phasenweise
vielleicht auf die zehen gehen noch
vorher vorne dann kommt man da schon in
ghana und ihr gleich wieder aus kurze
pause beine ab wir stehen auf wir machen
das kleine ohren zweiten durchgang aber
jetzt kommt noch wieder eine
koordinative nein koordinative aspekt
dazu diesmal ist nicht 1234 sondern rot
blau grün und gelb
das hatte umdenken rot ist eine
kniebeuge blau ist ein strick sprung
grün ist einmal um die eigene achse
drehen und gelb ist ein hampelmann
sprung ich wiederhole mich roth die
kniebeuge blau der strecke sprung
brauchst du jetzt weiter runter gehen
sondern nur wegspringen ja grün die
drehung um die eigene achse und geld der
hand man einmal sagt und wieder
möglichst schnell das ganze durchführen
meine von mir das signal wir machen
wieder lockeres laufen am stand und
fahre gerne an geld
gerhard bahmann konzentrieren gedroht
wir warten lieber genau wir laufen
weiter grün kurzen wir als team aus
boston wieder das ist super komplex
gehört jetzt einmal vorher ernst 234
kapital farben mit dem spiel mit
bewegung wie gesagt das ist ja ganz
schwierige sagt er wer merkt da kopf
kommt dann rein der körperarbeit dazu
und genau diese bahnen braucht man das
neuromuskuläre system von hier in
richtung muskulatur und das arbeiten mit
perfekt geht es jetzt weiter durchgang
aus
rot grün blau gelb rot jetzt komme eine
blau grün also der streck sprung mit
drehen ok lassen was an dieser stelle
ihr sechstes ist gar nicht so einfach ja
aber genau um das gehts wieder normal
stehen gar nicht so einfach das ganze
bis umzusetzen aber wie gesagt deswegen
trainieren weil es ja um auch da besser
zu werden
okay wir machen im zweiten durchgang los
wäre bitter und nikki zwar drei
wiederholungen schön langsam beine hoch
ausgleichen gleichgewicht halten ja wohl
die hände kennt natürlich andererseits
im gleichgewicht halten mitnehmen so ist
der gerne macht andererseits noch
schwieriger machen indem ich die hände
fixiert
keine frage es geht wie gesagt da jetzt
nicht darum dass die bauchmuskulatur ins
schwitzen kommt sondern es geht darum
dass wir ausgleichen dass die bewegungen
entsprechend ausgeglichen werden
ok eine übung machen wir doch die letzte
übung den wir jetzt machen die mir schon
ein bisschen aufbauen das ist die
standtage das ist super komplexe übung
in der gesamtbewegung und damit man sie
jetzt ein bisschen zeit dass man das
ganze herrichten
erste variante wie die stadtwaage
vorbereiten kann gerne ist welche genau
ich kann es mit anhalten machen wie man
es ohne anhalten schaffen möchte wie
kann es beispielsweise über eine übung
der mann hat jacob zum vorbereiten was
ist es auch vorbereitende übung da vier
füße war eine vorbereitende übung genau
die immer dann für die stadtwaage
brauchen und welche warne die ersten
übungen thema gemacht haben da entstand
richtig ich muss einmal im einbänden
stand stehen und dann meinen körper nach
vorn bringen um in die standtage
überhaupt hinein zu kommen und wir
schauen uns jetzt an das heißt hier geht
es am besten zu einem tisch hin zu einem
sessel hin oder stürzt vor die mauer so
dass ich irgendwann halten können es vor
ist das gleichgewicht nicht ganz so gut
passt ja das heißt nicht gesagt du das
bitte mal den protest vor ihr nehmt das
rechte bei einer standbein das linke
geht einmal nach oben und der oberkörper
geht nach unten ja und wenn jetzt
braucht und das gleichgewicht verliert
greifen natürlich hin und heute wir
haben ja dass niemand umfeld und sie
keiner weh tut oder verletzt wichtig
dabei ist das ist ein gerade im becken
bleibt und sie nicht gesteht eigentlich
super sicher ja da kennt man jetzt
probieren dass wir noch an mobile
unterlage unter der stand man
hineingehen
zuerst gehe aber mal die hände nach vor
ja ok wird schwieriger schon mehr zum
ausgleichen
kurze pausen gibt jahre bitte einmal du
da gerne fängt mit der heute position an
das ist die zweite variante die man gut
bringen können hebt einmal eine hand
hoch schaut das ausgleichen kann und
gibt mit der anderen weg er sagt ich das
jetzt einfach wie das funktioniert wie
man die position auch gut hinein kommen
kann
und da wäre wichtig das becken möglichst
gerade zum 640 wieder schwierig ja das
heißt das ist richtig auszugleichen das
ist die hohe kunst des bei der standtage
nicht gebiete anderes beinamen otto
kenner sehr gut passt jetzt haben wir
fünf übungen die man euch gezeigt haben
wie gesagt integrierten alltag das ganze
wir machen jetzt noch ein zweiter
durchgang mit ausgewählten übungen noch
mit unterschiedlichen varianten macht
das game mit und versuchte diese
bewegungen wie gesagt immer wieder in
euren alltag zu integrieren
weil das training wird von den meisten
die die viel trainieren vernachlässigt
und ist war ganz wichtige art des
trainings ja welche magst du regelmäßig
welche variante welche übung ja okay
diese drei teilschritte die probieren
jetzt aus 30 sekunden rechtes bein auf
der mobilen unterlage genau einfach mal
im einbein stand zu stehen wie gesagt
das kann immer und überall zu hause
machen bei der kaffeepause
meine kollege fragt warum stehst im
einbein stand und macht zwischen drei
brennende augen zu kurze erklärung ich
trainiere mein gleichgewicht und dann
sieht es schon klar sein
ja wir wechseln die seite auch spannung
richtig kann man nicht oft genug sagen
ganz wichtig vernachlässigten auf diese
grundspannung aus der rumpfmuskulatur
heraus genau und das ausgehalten wie
gesagt ganz wichtig kurz runter kurz aus
lockern
die zweite variante war also erst einmal
stand zweite war
augen schließen bietet die wir jetzt
einigermaßen sicher gestanden sind
probieren es mit geschlossenen augen aus
die die neue jetzt da schon viel
ausgleichen mussten bleiben bei der
variante oder gehen von der mobilen
unterlage herunter und probieren einmal
zu stehen mit geschlossenen augen im
heim einstand im optimalfall neben der
mauer wo im jahr wieder abfangen kann
und bittet die augen öffnen bevor
bevor man stützt ok erst einmal
konzentrieren und dann mal die augen
schließen versuchen hier haben wir sie
das kommt ganz viel bewegung ins spiel
er wird ganz für ausgleichen das ist
ganz ganz wichtig ok kurz wieder aus
lockern das ist schon sehr anstrengend
für gesagt für die tiefliegende
muskulatur und nehmen wir die zweite
seite einmal ruhig stehen einmal
versuchen mit offenen augen an den
richtigen stand zu finden und erst einen
guten stand haben jetzt ag langsam in
die mit geschlossenen augen genau schon
ausgleichen konzentrieren und wieder
auflockern wieder runterkommen auslagern
ich sage mal ganz für ein ein weinstand
macht es manchmal eine variante in arbon
und nikki du darfst das aussuchen was
machen wir zwei mal genau und das ganze
mit der mobilen unterlage das macht man
aber zweites mal super übung müsste
wieder mathe bei den beinen unter den
händen haben oder erreicht da wäre max
herre macht's mit liegestütze ja kommen
die stücke vor mit einer matten bitte ja
genau der macht noch einmal die
körperlich schwierigere variante wie er
war sehr gut zum ausgleichen ist und sie
nicht gemacht noch mal die matten
variante im vierfüßlerstand genau normen
zur erinnerung wie bei mir das ganze auf
gibt es einmal die hände nehmen und die
beine unter niki das ganze damals so auf
das immer mit einem bein oder mit einer
hand anfangen wir fangen jetzt mal mit
der rechten hand an zum ausstrecken
genau das geht meistens relativ gut
jetzt nehmen wir mal das linke bein mit
dazu schön langsam genau vielleicht
einmal ausstrecken und mit den
zehenspitzen am boden und erst langsam
los lösen so dass sie immer was zum
ausgleichen habe ja genau und dann auch
mal die seite wechseln
und auch hier lag spannung des sees
angespannt die rum spannung an sich ist
immer ein begleiter im training er hat
ohne um spannung kommt es zu kann
training und einmal auf die seite
wechseln weil sie kunden
okay ich gehe mal die matte auf die
seite und das handtuch
eine letzte koordinative variante haben
auch für euch mit und schaue man es
angeht muss man hoffen dass man die nici
kontrollieren hat das team sehr gut
umsetzen kann
ja es macht nämlich kombiniert erklärt
sie glaubt sie war schon was kommt 1
linker hand zwei rechte hand drei linkes
knie vier rechtes knie
das wissen wir noch am anfang dann haben
wir gehabt roth die kniebeuge blaue den
strick sprung grün die drehung und geld
den hampelmann so weit hat mit folgen
können
ich hoffe ja ja lockeres laufen am stand
garrett kontrolliert das so kontrolliert
ja und fangen wir einfach an
sagen wir mal ein ja aber all das
funktioniert gut dann sagen mal geld 3
jawoll
niki ist gut dann mag man ja weil der
strom mit der kniebeuge da manchmal grün
gelb und ihr macht natürlich mit ja also
quasi das nicht das zeug haben mieter
und schaut dass das genauso gut
hinkriegt 12 blau perfekt ja damals hat
man jetzt danke dass du bist das mal
teurer machen müssten für die nici war
diese diese variante vielleicht sogar
spur zu wenig damit hat man vielleicht
noch mathematikaufgabe zwischen rhein
geben so die wurzel simon ein skoda
sowas annäherungsweise rechnen das
kriegt man innerhalb ist was sie machen
man muss so viel reiz wie möglich bieten
dass man nicht überfordert aber an
er fordert damit man wirklich ein cooles
training zusammen können ja leute heute
ist und es nicht länger ich hoffe ihr
habt es von diesem sensomotorik training
gleichgewichtstraining
koordinationstraining einiges mitnehmen
können wir sehen einander morgen zum
körperlich intensivsten teil der woche
dem military fitnesstraining das wird
einerseits wären wir beginnen mit 30
sekunden belasten 30 pause und der
steigern im zweiten durchgang auf ein
klassisches tabata protokoll 20 sekunden
belastung zehn sekunden pause mit
ausgewählten übungen so dass es ihr
daheim mitmachen kannst ohne zusatzgerät
das heißt für morgen die große
wasserflasche handwerklich zum schweiß
abwischen und die marke zum trainieren
und dann geht es los wir sehen einander
morgen um 10 uhr 30
wir freuen uns und schönen tag noch